all right many of you wrote in about my
coverage yesterday of Bobby Kennedy
Junior's candidacy the reactions were
all over the map people saying David
you're wrong this is God's gift to
politics or David you're wrong he's way
worse than what you're saying he
actually has no redeeming qualities and
you're not being tough enough on Bobby
Kennedy Jr maybe because you know him I
know him I sat with him at dinner once
um and then people who said I
appreciated you giving some context
about Bobby Kennedy Jr I want to be
super clear
the negatives about Bobby Kennedy Jr are
single-handedly disqualifying of him as
an even remotely serious presidential
candidate and I'm going to give you
examples today so I'm not going to be
wishy-washy and act like well there's
pros and cons and maybe they cancel out
so maybe you'll vote for the guy no what
I'm telling you is although there are
some things about him that I like
there are concerns so bad that they are
uniquely disqualifying I'm going to give
you one example okay tonight tonight
Bobby Kennedy Jr is hosting a so-called
Health policy Roundtable you can RSVP
and participate if you want okay
this health policy Roundtable is being
held with dangerous vectors of
disinformation many of whom we've
covered on the program already these are
not just you know folks with slightly
um different views about vaccination or
whatever these are dangerous and in some
cases seemingly certifiably insane
lunatics and hosting a health policy
Roundtable with these people
is single-handedly disqualifying take a
look at this Mr Kennedy will meet with
leading critics of prevailing Health
policy including Dr Joe Mercola Dr
Sherry Tenpenny Dr Pierre Corey Dr
Patrick gentempo Maureen McDonnell Dell
big tree Mickey Willis and Sayer G let's
go back to Sherry 10 penny in a moment
okay these people
many of whom we've talked about before
Joseph Mercola is a widely known
purveyor of pseudoscience and conspiracy
theories fined by the FDA for making
false and misleading claims about his
products and covid-19 treatments
dangerous not a serious person okay
Pierre Corey advocates for the use of
ivermectin as a coveted treatment or
cure despite the fact that there's no
actual randomized controlled trials
showing that that works
um Patrick gentempo chiropractor and
entrepreneur who made an anti-vaxx
documentary that's who Bobby Kennedy is
meeting with uh Maureen McDonald
holistic health educator who is
anti-vaxx and spreads false information
about vaccines every single one of these
people Dell big tree founded an
anti-vaccine group produces propaganda
movies
Mickey Willis activist who also promotes
uh vaccine disinformation has been
denounced by serious medical ex okay so
all of these people and then of course
Sherry Tenpenny if the name Sherry
tempany rings a bell it's because we've
talked about her before here is
self-described vaccine expert Sherry
Tenpenny explaining that this year
this year folks it's almost July and it
hasn't happened this year
every one of us will have five or even
10 people we know Dead from the vaccine
now we're seeing the tsunami of deaths
that I've been talking about since the
beginning of 21 right millions of people
are going to die you know when Judy
mikovitz came out on pandemic at the
beginning of that and said that
that more than 50 million people are
going to die and everybody was like whoa
and when they started interviewing me
and I and asked me what did I think
about that number I said it's way too
low
it's going to be much more than 50
million people in America wow
and we're already starting to see it
we're not so the tsunami of deaths is
coming it's already here and I believe
that remember Bobby Kennedy Jr is having
an event tonight with this woman as if
she is an expert on health what's
happening now and is is starting to
happen now is the tsunami of regret
of the people that fell for the lies
your friends and family members and
parents and children and all they did to
your grandchildren just could not be
told otherwise but now that people are
dying like flies I mean my business
partner has 83 close people in his life
that have died I don't even believe her
business partner has 83 close people in
his life never mind 83 people that have
died 83.
it's the beginning
and I predict that by the end of this
year every person in this room and every
person listening behind here is going to
know a minimum of five probably ten or
more close friends and family members
that have died from these shots okay I
still we're almost in July now I
understand we've got half of the year
left I don't know a single person that's
died of the vaccine and everybody I know
is vaccinated that's who Bobby Kennedy
is having an event with one more Sherry
10 Penny clip just to really drive home
how insane this is uh here she says that
it's a vaccinating kids as a form of
child sacrifice this is happening in
America people right and it's your job
to stop everybody you know and wake them
up and shove it in their face and if
they defund you off of social media who
cares now it's about trying to save
unborn babies and pregnant women it's
about the they they now are actually
starting a trial and to give these shots
to six month olds
this is child sacrifice this is the
Resurgence of child sacrifice from the
days of the Babylonian Mystery Schools
yeah and then she goes into a religious
nonsense all right folks so listen uh I
think it's great that Bobby Kennedy
wants a higher minimum wage and wants to
deal with homelessness and whatever this
event this event is uniquely
disqualifying
let's dig in now a little more into his
view on vaccines